hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
Game of Thrones is going back to the
Martel so I thought it'd be fun to do a
video for the Dornish master plan the
plan itself involves a lot of book
characters that the show isn't doing so
I'm gonna try and explain how I think
the show is gonna change it just a
little bit
amongst the powers that be in the world
there are several plans to put someone
new on the Iron Throne
you have Stan is trying to put himself
on the throne there's Daenerys who seems
like he's kind of temporarily forgotten
her quest to retake it there's the young
Griff plot that we know that the show
isn't doing and then there's house
Martell in the Dornish master plan we're
just getting to know the Martel's now so
they might even spill that into season
six the pacing of the Martell plan on
the show seems relatively slow compared
to what's going on up in the north
however long they drag all these
storylines out you know into season
eight however many seasons the show ends
up going we'll still have a couple
different plans to put someone new on
the Iron Throne but I think the show is
doing is just combining some of the
elements from different book plots so
I'm gonna be jumping between book stuff
and show stuff so just general spoiler
warning for everything that's happened
on the show so far and everything in the
books that the show has already done so
the Dornish master plan isn't like some
secret murder plot is actually a secret
marriage pact that involves Arianne
Martell and viscera star garyun the pact
itself was signed in Braavos with the
sea Lord as witness Oberyn signed for
the Martel's and Sir William Derry
signed for the Targaryens obviously the
show hasn't done so William Derry so
they're probably not to replace him with
someone else in the show the Sealord of
Braavos served as witness to the signing
of the pact we got a brief look at that
building whenever arya first came to
Braavos when she was travelling through
the canals he's a big character in the
context of the books but someone we
haven't met on the show so he might show
up in a future season both Braavos and
Dorne will probably continue to be big
things next season
so the original pact was signed a long
time ago when both viscera and Daenerys
were really young the original intention
of the pact was to combine Dornish
forces with Targaryen forces you know
Targaryen supporters in March on the
throne and take Robert Baratheon down he
was signed a long long time ago
obviously a lot has changed since then
Robert Baratheon has already died
Joffrey came and went now we have Tommen
on the throne so already this Martell
marriage pact has gone through several
different iterations even viscera Scott
himself anointed by Khal Drogo got his
face melted off kind of complicating
things a little bit more
to the show isn't doing some of the
characters that serve as backups for the
plan namely like Quentyn Martell the
closest thing we have to Quentin in the
books is Tristan and he is betrothed to
Marcela Bharati and right now
here's what I think the writers of the
show stepped in to simplify things quite
a bit
by combining a couple different plots to
take the Iron Throne Varys told Tyrion
about a Targaryen restoration plot what
I'm hoping the show does is combine that
you know whatever version of that is
doing with the Dornish master plan just
going on what we've seen on the show so
far the only thing we know is that
Illyrio is a big part of that plot he
also implies there's like a consortium
of really powerful people backing the
plan to I'll say with pretty good
certainty that they've roped the young
grift plot into that namely because
we've already seen young grift grayscale
stuff get married to Tyrion and Jorah
story mostly just Jorah not so much
Tyrion I know a lot of people were
wondering whether or not Tyrion got
greyscale I think if he would have
gotten Gracie off the show would have
wanted to give him that he would have
given him that Jorah moment where he
opened his sleeve up and you saw it so
they've already given a lot of the
Targaryen restoration young Griff stuff
to Daenerys his storyline logically they
would probably try to marry some of the
Martell storyline to that - the other
option is is that they could be doing a
version of the area and Martell plot the
show is doing a lot of area and Martel
story in the books through the sand
snake so what you've seen from the sand
snakes so far that's basically Airy and
stuff namely the desire to start a war
with King's Landing with the purpose of
taking down the Lannisters and the
Baratheon
technically it's the same group of
people but really it's like the
Lannisters that the Martel's hate
sometimes it's hard to tell which new
characters know that Tommen is really
Jaime's son and he really isn't a
Baratheon
so sometimes it's easier when you talk
about taking down the Iron Throne you
talk about taking down the Lannisters
because most people still have a pretty
good idea of what's going on between
Jaime and Cersei and if you really want
to take it a step further it's really
Tywin Lannister that everyone hates
especially the Martel's most of the
Dornish master plan has it spelled out
in the books was born after the death of
Elia Martell remember she's Oberyn and
Duran's younger sister she was killed in
the sack of King's Landing by the
mountain on Tywin Lannister's orders
they knew about the mountains confession
and they know the connection between the
mountain and Tywin Lannister even though
word of Tywin Lannister's death has
probably spread all
over the realm prince Turan isn't just
gonna forget about revenge
isn't gonna forget about the death of
Oberyn or his sister Elia we've only
just met prince Turan on the show and
even though he seems kind of reluctant I
think of him is having the cunning of
Varys without like the really chatty
mouth he explains that he does want
revenge but he doesn't want to start a
war with King's Landing that's where you
enter Dornish master plan territory like
even though he doesn't want to start a
war he still has something burning in
the background the problem is is that a
lot of the people that were part of that
plan have either died or the show has
cut out so it seems like what the show
is doing is just combining that with the
Targaryen restoration did Ferris spoke
of I know everyone's also wondering
where Varys went he will show up again -
I know it's hard to trust the show to
bring people back after they sail off
into the night like Andry like never to
be seen again but I do think that Varys
will be back he's way too big a
character to not come back based on the
pacing of the show it seems like what
they're spending most of their time
focusing on you know with the the dorm
plot is Jamie rescuing Marcella or
trying to rescue Marcella so if the show
is going to marry the Martel's to this
Targaryen restoration we probably won't
find out about it for at least two or
three more episodes the name of episode
six is actually the house Martell motto
it's all about the strength the
fortitude the independence of door and
as a nation inside the realm so what I'm
hoping is is that they spell out a
little bit about what's going on inside
door beyond them just reacting to
oberyn's death because that's all we've
seen so far
like they find out oberyn's dead they're
pissed the sand snakes want to start a
war prince Turan is just biding his time
also complicating things
sir Barristan Selmy is kind of like
Daenerys his old advisor he's the one
that tells her about things that
happened a long time ago he is gone now
so if anyone knew about any kind of
Martell master plan or marriage pact
they are probably dead I just think it's
funny how notorious weddings have become
on Game of Thrones
you have the red wedding the purple
wedding then you have all the weddings
this season - it's like each new season
there are even more weddings here's my
big question for you guys you know
clearly the Martel's want to take down
the Lannisters want to take down King's
Landing in general do you think that
they're going to marry them - what Varys
was talking about the Targaryen
restoration just in terms of the amount
of exposition a story like this would
take there's some pretty big moves to be
made so that's why I think a lot of this
will spill into season six they're
taking all season
with this Sansa Jon Snow Hart home plot
so there's no way they're just gonna
brush over Targaryen restoration in a
single season there's just way too much
stuff going on with all the characters
right now one of the big criticisms of
the show has been that you know it sets
something up and then it kind of drops
it like gand reek kendrys the best
example just kind of rolling off into
the night I think at a certain point you
know before the final season it will
address all those things it's like if
you watched x-files in the 90s even
though it seemed like it gave birth to
like a thousand different alien invasion
plot lines by the final season it
explained everything so the show isn't
gonna tease any big things that it
doesn't have any intentions of paying
off so if it seems like something is
going nowhere it just means like it's
not going anywhere right now
they will circle back around and get
everything just comparing the books in
the show like that's one of the reasons
why George R Martin originally planned a
trilogy that ballooned into seven books
just because so many different plot
lines branched out and he has to address
everything he's even talking about
writing an eighth book maybe now he
could just keep going forever the show
can't do that so it's just adjusting
this story so that it can hit everything
by the final season whatever that ends
up being I almost feel like it'd be
worse for the shows to do like
everything from the books and then just
have to drop plot lines because it
doesn't have enough time to address them
that's really where spin-off shows come
in don't worry like I'm sure HBO will do
everything in its power to start a
spin-off show where it can address all
these other things especially stuff that
predates the plotline of the show right
now so big reminder episode 6 tonight
I'll post the video after the episode
airs be sure to subscribe to get it I'll
also have a new round of the giveaway
it'll be an HBO now subscription if
they're any bonus videos you guys want
me to do that you don't see in might you
know my Game of Thrones playlist just
let me know in the comments hopefully by
the end of the season we'll get through
most of book 5 so I can start doing more
book related stuff while you guys wait
for that next episode you can click here
for last week's episode and you can
click here to learn all about Leon of
Stark thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you
[Music]